[Music]
on today's show we talked to a man whose
new stepson is trashing his home and he
wants to know what to do next we also
talked to a woman whose parents are
getting divorced dad has gotten to drugs
and she wants to know what to do next
stay tuned
[Music]
hey what's up what's up it's john with
the dr john deloney's show
hope you're doing well wherever you
happen to be i hope it's not
freezing
covered in snow it's it's cold here but
it's beautiful outside and we have a
packed studio audience out here it's
great to see y'all actually there's
three and a half of you
held your little one seven months
three months
that's that's a third so it's three and
a third of you out there it's awesome to
see you
um so hey we're so new books out make
sure you please please please go to john
dilling.com and
pre-order this thing it comes with a
bajillion dollars worth of
free counseling a month free counseling
better help and audiobooks all kind of
stuff
i was recording the audiobook the other
day and
i had this genius idea that gummy bears
would help coat my throat and you just
stand there for hours and you're reading
and reading and they were working great
but then james pointed out we're reading
the section in the book where we talk
about
what our food does to our mental health
and our physical health and
james is like this is kind of ironic
that you're deceiving the audience by
reading this section about sugar and
junk food while you're mainlining gummy
candies and then chris miller decides to
kick me while i'm down and says
sends me this meme and it says
i hope that when i inevitably choke to
death on gummy bears people will just
say i was killed by bears and leave it
at that and i actually loved that way to
go man way to go
but hey james you kind of gave me a
i get like a
uh what do you call it like a ethical
crisis
i quit eating gummy bears over the
weekend i just went cold turkey i'm done
i'm off the i'm off the sauce
proud of you i'm never having one again
as long as i live i will never eat
another one
this is the irony of you asking the the
journal prompts at the end of the
chapter saying how often are you eating
foods that are in packages and right
below you right before the microphone is
a bag of common candies
listen
hope this feels good james all right
let's go to michael in philadelphia hey
michael what's up man
hey dr john how are you today i'm
you clearly see i'm still trying to
figure out how to use this phone so
sorry for hanging up on you just now i'm
an idiot that's okay i'll get it yeah
you'll get used to it i know right you
think how about it hey so what's up man
how can i help
okay um
i'll give you the short story and you
take it from there um
basically what i have is uh my wife and
i are 57 years old
we started dating about four years ago
and about a year ago
she moved in with me
and we got married last september
now
since she moved in with me a year ago
she let her son who's 23 years old
move into her home
we both had our own home she moved into
mine and she let her son move into her
home now her son
is a hoarder
and
we're now dealing with
a year later
with um
we have junk cars all over the lawn we
have car parts all over her property
uh the inside of the house is a mess
and
[Music]
my instinct is to tell her
give them uh give them an ultimatum or
give them a deadline say hey you need to
buy such and such a date you got to get
rid of this stuff
or else
and she's got a very difficult time
doing that with him
and i'm having a difficult time
with her difficulty
yeah because
you know i don't want to overstep my
bounds in a sense of you know me
stepping in and
dictating things to him you know i'm
trying to do it through her
so are you
did y'all sign a prenup of any sort how
have you divided up your finances
well
since we got married and i've been a a
dave ramsey baby stepper for the last
five years so
we've basically combined all of our our
all of our finances and everything is
together
and uh so the reason i'm asking is is
at the beginning of this call you were
talking about your house and her house
and i know it's different when you're
getting married at 57 it can feel
different but
it would sound like when you get married
it's your house and you're in y'all's
house in y'all's house
correct and that's the way we're that's
the way we're treating it
for the sake of this discussion i just
want to let you know we both had our
separate homes you know right now as far
as i'm concerned what's mine is hers and
was hers there you go okay so yeah
do you need this house i mean is it
gonna help pay the bills is it part of a
retirement plan
it is part of a retirement plan okay um
we we um are in the process of planning
our retirement and
we will need that home and my home uh
to be able to to do what we want to do
in retirement okay
so
a couple of things to think through and
i know you know these things i'm just
going to say them out loud just for both
of us okay
the first thing is the 23 year old son
this didn't just crop up
when he was 22.
so my guess is there's a dynamic between
the two of them and any other family
members
his his biological father etc that has
led to
some sort of
traumatic childhood or challenges that
have led to this moment some sort of
interaction is that fair
yes okay
and
often did he have a rough childhood
he did okay he did he didn't he
primarily didn't have a father figure in
his life okay um his father
although he's been in contact with his
son
was not really a um for the lack of a
better term a disciplinarian okay as far
as in his in his upbringing and so does
your wife does his mom have a hard time
is she still living out of i'm gonna
make it up to you
she's a hard time holding him
accountable
i i i yeah i think par i think that is
part of it yes okay yes all right so
ultimately here i think we start with
you and your wife
because this is sounds like it's the
first big test of your new marriage but
y'all are on way different pages here
and i may
i know there's some uh
there's some uh what do you call it
there's some translation issues between
some of my best friends on planet earth
are from the philadelphia area and we
used to laugh about the translation
issues between texas and philadelphia
but
i can pick up
i feel like i'm picking up tell me if
i'm wrong i'm picking up
you
are starting to look at her a little bit
differently like how are you gonna let
somebody do this to your stuff
and
she says well it's just my son
and now this is
is leaving being about some guys trash
in your house to oh man who did i marry
am i right or wrong tell me i'm wrong
um
to a degree but i i wouldn't i wouldn't
i here here's my frustration comes with
her
um
being
like
i guess the best way to put this is that
i you know my what i say to her every
once in a while is that
this because i have i also have two 23
year olds also i have two i have twins
that are 23 years old
and i at one point made the mistake of
saying well i wouldn't let my kids do
this no don't say that and i i know i
know i know
you learned about it you learned you
said you're sorry it's good
no yeah i did and and i also know that
um you know he he's also been diagnosed
with you know adhd and
you know she has uh she's been diagnosed
with with depression and so i try to
i look at first i was like you know what
the hell's going why are you letting him
do this
to now i kind of sit back and i kind of
try to talk
it out with her and say well what kind
of
what
how are we going to handle this how are
we going to what are we going to do
i mean obviously you can't just say
we're going to kick you out of your head
you know we're going to kick you out of
the house but
so hey what i'm telling you my father
would do to me michael that's that's
exactly what has to happen
and
adhd
is not an excuse to trash somebody's
home
right adhd is not an excuse or ocd or a
clinical hoarder
that's not an excuse to
destroy somebody's property or to not
take care of yourself or to not be
hygienic or whatever the struggles and
challenges are that are happening
those are a context that is a
that is um
a way you lean it's a way that your body
naturally responds to certain things
whether it's environmental or it's
um genetic well it's actually it's a
combination of both those but there's
there's a bunch of reasons
so i want you to keep in your in your
mind both and
yes my wife is is has a tendency to run
low she's had a ch like man she got left
the guy was a jerk whatever she's had
struggles for who knows how long
right she struggles with depression and
she's got to set up an environment where
she can be successful financially or
she's gonna have food to eat where she
can
help her kids be accountable she can
take care of her family and so and same
with him he's got
struggles of all sorts no no question
about that
and
he's got to have a situation that holds
him accountable
and he's got to have a situation where
people care about him and love about him
but aren't going to enable him to
destroy something because here's the
thing he's just going to go to the next
thing and he's going to go to the next
thing and he's going to go to the next
thing
so right and and yeah
so the question i think between you and
your wife is
i know that you
let me i'm thinking about me and my wife
um if somebody came in and said somebody
yelled and screamed or grown up yelled
and screamed at our daughter who's six
in the parking lot and
um it's the parent of one of her
classmates
my
tendency to respond
i mean my default setting in that
situation
i'm probably going to go to jail right
i'm not going to handle that well
she on the other hand my wife would be
able to handle that differently and i
say be able to i could be able to
understand my my tendency
and so
she would say i'm going to have this
conversation first
and i would exhale really deeply and say
that's probably wise
and then in a week or so or a couple of
days you see what i'm saying so i want
you to stay on your wife and say
the reality is we have to have this
house
the reality is what's work what's what
we're allowing to happen right now with
our son
uh with our home is not working so we
all can agree that something different
has to happen
honey i have heard you that you can't be
the one that makes this call
right can i have permission can i have
permission to make this call
i will sit with you on your side of the
table when we have a hard conversation
with your son
i will you you get what i'm saying i
want you to say that's what i'm looking
for how can i support you as we have to
do what we have to do
because with someone struggling with
depression she knows
that he's got to get help she knows that
she can't let him just trash the house
and the fact that she's not
i must say can't um can't act on that
makes the depression worse right it
makes that shame spiral deeper and
deeper and deeper
yeah it could be that she writes a
letter it could be that she any number
of ways but i want you to reach out to
her and say okay we all know this has to
happen
and also i don't want to put more
pressure on you than you're capable of
carrying right now i am your husband i
agreed to partner up with this deal
what can i do
and then lean into and you maybe have to
be the bad guy in this thing and you may
kick him out and she blames you for it
and that's where you and her and the
marriage counselor work she has she
already done that
well she she has but then you know he
doesn't do anything and kind of falls on
deaf ears and he doesn't really
you know um okay mom okay mom i'll i'll
start cleaning everything up and i'll
start getting things taken care of and
and then you know a week goes by and two
weeks goes by and you know a month goes
by and the conditions are still the same
and nothing's changed and
so take him out of the equation
take him out of the equation if you had
just a renter would you let him destroy
your home like this
well no i've i no of course not
absolutely not no chance yeah so
struggles and challenges are not excuses
to
destroy
so in supporting her in in you know
coming to some sort of a um
solution to this i mean is it
is this coming down to an ultimatum like
hey you've got until
you know such and such a date to have
this taken care of or
we're going to be forced to
do something we don't
necessarily and something we don't want
to have to do so i would sit with him
and say you son hold all the cards
anything that happens after this point
is something that you are choosing
i have drawn the boundary i have decided
that i'm not going to have anybody trash
my home
i've decided that i've looked at the
math
and i need this home your mom and i need
this home
to be able to eat when we're older
everything else you're going to choose
you're going to choose how long you're
going to live in this house you're going
to choose to um
whether the police come and escort you
out of here and all of this stuff is
thrown in the dump
you get to choose all of these things
but here's what it's going to happen by
this date everything will be cleaned out
of the yard period full stop
or i'm sending the sheriff over and
we're going to evict you
or you'll start you can't do that it'd
be 30 days and plus another 30 days so
you have to sign the eviction papers but
you hear what i'm saying and when it's
like you're kicking me out no young man
you chose to not ha live in this
particular house because you chose to
keep everything out there
even has taken that sort of stance
before too you know like right away he
tries to turn it around like it's our
fault that we're
coming down on him yep
and hey i would stop that nonsense in
the middle of a conversation
like we'll you guys
stop
we're only working forward today
so effective today this house gets
cleaned up
and i'll pay for three months of mental
health care for you if you need to go
see a counselor
i will
i don't know i'll get a group of buddies
from work and help load up the
junk in one of those day trailers or i
mean those you know those
portable
i don't know they're those big
metal pod things yeah right you know
yeah and i've and i've suggested all
those things you just mentioned and and
i have but what you haven't done you
haven't though put it put a or what
and yes we are at ultimatum time
okay
because michael here's what's next you
know what's next your marriage
oh i i agree i agree i mean it hasn't
really put too much of a toll on that's
coming yeah it's coming like i
i know like i see the clouds coming yeah
it's coming and
man i don't want that for you i don't
want that for your wife i don't want
that for this 23 year old
yeah and and i'm trying really hard and
i know you are brother i also don't want
to and i also don't want to paint him as
like you know like like some kind of a
he's a really good kid of course he's
trying to take away from what he's doing
he's struggling you know i mean yeah
he's i mean he'd do anything for anybody
if i mentioned i needed a shed in my
backyard he'd be there the next day you
know with tools and building me a shed
in my backyard but when he should be
doing taking care of that well and the
one person he can't care for is him
no one's ever showed him what that looks
like
yes yes and this may be the first time
somebody says here's what care and love
looks like and it's holding firm
boundaries holding you accountable and
for the first time when i tell you and
you need to say this in a good
philadelphia accent
[Laughter]
a bunch of people in his life have said
hey man you got to do this or else and
they haven't held true and he needs to
walk away
probably you know what put it in writing
put it in writing and hand it to him he
needs to walk away from the table
understanding if this doesn't happen
this guy's serious
my mom is serious
all of this though brother starts with
y'all too having a conversation you and
your wife
going out and saying what's our what's
our what's our or what moment
what is our
plan and how can i support and love you
this is your son
but it's our home how can i support and
love you i'll be the bad guy i'll have
the conversation i will lay out the plan
i'll type it whatever you need to do
but this has got to happen it's got to
happen
be right back on the dr john delaney
show
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john deloney show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance i can't get off work and time
to go see somebody it's way across town
what do i do because i want help with my
anxiety my depression my relationships
are hanging on by a thread i want to be
a better mom i gotta process this trauma
that happened to me when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with betterhelp because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours
dr john doloni show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com all right hey we're back
jack let's go to suzanne in cleveland oh
hi oh what's up suzanne
hi dr john hey big win for ohio
yesterday right
oh yeah
you don't have any idea what i'm talking
about do you nope nope
you are awesome
dude the bengals won man
i'm really sad about that but uh yeah
we're super dating the show
what'd you say james yeah yeah i was
just gonna say point out to people that
by the time this airs the super bowl oh
yeah by the time this show is over the
super bowl will be long over but uh
there's an ohio team never never it's a
game called football it's a whole mess
all right so what's up suzanne how can i
help
okay so this is a lot but bear with me
bring it on
uh my parents are in the middle of a
very messy divorce it's probably an
understatement um
and my dad over the past year has been
making progressively
worse and worse and worse choices and um
i'm just trying to figure out how to
handle all of it and
what my position is to like where to
step in um
yeah what a process so you use some very
eloquent distancing language i would
love what is what does messy divorce
mean
um
well oh there's a lot
uh messy divorce like they can't like
they they won't they can't be in like
the same room together my parents and my
dad's refusing to find divorce papers so
it's like he's just kind of getting
pushed along through all of this
what started all of this
what started all of it um
well
oh goodness a lot my dad growing up was
kind of abusive and
no such thing as kind of abusive what
kind of abusive was it
uh
verbally and
physically to my mom i would say okay
and financially yeah
very much so financially
what was that what was the inciting
incident that she just said enough's
enough
um
we found out that he there is some
infidelity on his part um
there is infidelity on her my mom's part
as well that's kind of what's
started the whole like downfall of
everything and then he wanted to work
things out and then
yeah and then
it got the end was when it we found out
that it was him too
and your mom just said let's just call
it
uh my mom changed all the locks on the
door
so
so
you all grow up he's abusive he's
physically abusive he's verbally abusive
he plays power games with money
your mom
your mom
has eyes for somebody else has an affair
or two or three or four
and
he finds out and says we should we
should change let's figure let's come
back together
and then she says all right i'm in and
then she finds out he's been cheating on
her
and she says i mean
so we should like get back together that
was probably like six years
and
of them trying to make things work and
but it was
a lot of counseling sessions and
nothing came out of it my dad was very
that's when the peak abusive stuff
happened
i would for sure watch this tv show by
the way for sure
oh oh you haven't even gotten to like
the dc part yet all right so way better
when you say he's making increasingly
worse choices what does that mean
okay so in
the last year
he um
like started partying pretty hard and
then um yes how old is he
uh
65
it seems like a good time to start
partying all right 50 56 56 or 58.
somewhere
[Music]
okay so we just decided i'm going to let
that
okay i'm start partying then what
happened yeah he started partying um and
then last year he joined a motorcycle
gang do your dads and sons of anarchy
uh yeah yeah
uh
so yeah that's that's been a bit
frustrating um because i can't even have
like a conversation with him anymore
without that being all that's talked
about just his gang did he is he
so motorcycle gang it's got a
connotation to it but i knew some guys
that were in a um a great
great group is he looking for connection
and camaraderie or is he is he
yeah
definitely looking for connection and
camaraderie but they're
they're getting into some not so good
things okay all right okay
so
it's not influencing him in a good way
like we grew up in church and stuff and
there's like
i i just i just the what kicked off all
of this and my call to you is that i
just found out
about three weeks ago um that
he
um
pressured my little brother who is about
21 into doing math with him
i'm wondering if it's a problem and i
was told this by my brother in complete
confidence what do you mean you're
wondering if this is a problem yeah no i
i get that it's very good okay good
more so like a like an addiction problem
because he's also lost like a hundred
pounds in the last two months methyl do
that to you yes yeah yes so
what's your question i wasn't supposed
to tell anybody about this
and
my
my dad has custody of my brothers on the
weekends and i'm not supposed to tell my
mom about this but then i did tell her
but now we all don't know what to do
because i don't want to ruin the
relationship between
me and my brother because
i told my mom
tell me about it have to be confronted
the kids in the custody there's children
involved
yeah i have a 10 year old brother and a
15 year old brother
smokes yeah so
this conversation
just took a a
significant turn
and
yeah so number one i was poking some fun
and all this i know this is super hard
for you
before we get into what we need to do
have you sat down and grieved this
this is shapeshifter for you
um
there's been a lot of crying i don't
know if i've fully grieved it it
definitely keeps me up at night yeah
exactly
um there's a couple of things i'm i'm
married out of the house with i just had
my first daughter uh
two months ago so like
like yeah it's definitely like just
overflowing into that relationship so i
don't know it's a lot big time yeah so
my guess is you're gonna have to spend
some time
whether it's with you in a notebook
writing some letters some imaginary
letters that you're never gonna send
one of which is probably when you're a
little girl to your dad like what was so
bad about me as a seven-year-old that
you had to yell at me like that
and how dare you hit mommy right
and yeah you need to
process that
you need to process when you found out
that mom had cheated on dad
and yeah like mom that's not how you
raised it like what happened like what
you know what i mean
and then you're gonna have to process
and grieve watching your dad literally
wither away in front of you
yeah
and then
this is a both and to this
you gotta grieve that hard stuff
and there's a whole that's a whole
process given what you grew up with if
you haven't spent time with a counselor
you probably should
um if you haven't ever sat down and told
your husband
some of the hard stuff you probably
should
yeah he's really supportive he knows a
lot of
he's probably too involved in all of it
as well well he loves you right and he's
not going to be that kind of guy you
probably married well to you didn't
repeat the cycle did you
no
it's awesome
he's an awesome dad and
i love him
so what will happen is
as your daughter gets older your body
will begin remembering her trajectory
through this system
it will remember you at four and it will
remember you at seven it'll remember you
at 14 when your dad said this or did
that or his buddy came over and looked
at you like this those things will begin
to come up as your daughter grows up
if they haven't already
and so
dealing with this trauma dealing with
this
grieving this is so important for you
for your relationship with your daughter
if your relationship with your husband
but
for you for you like i said it's keeping
you up at night and i want you to have a
night of sleep okay i want you to have
peace
so here's the both hand so you gotta
grieve
what happened you gotta own what
happened and
you gotta deal with the tornado that's
sitting right on top of your house right
now
yeah if you know somebody's sharing meth
with with their child
with their 21 year old
then i'm going to sit down with my
younger brother and say hey i need you
to know as the adult
how old are you
24 yeah as the older sister
i'm gonna break your heart here i'm
gonna make you sad
and
i have to you have to know that i really
wrestled with this
i wrestled so hard i called some yahoo
on a podcast and asked what he hated me
mean
he needs to know that this wasn't easy
but that you have to throw a flag on
this
because you cannot in good conscience or
in
without violation of the law
send your brothers
back into this man's
mess you can't yeah
and so what has to happen is it's gonna
be a mess it's gonna i mean you gotta
know you didn't create this mess
you're getting in the middle of it to
help solve it because you're got two
children involved here
yeah
if this was just your 60 year old man
like
like just
man
just kind of spinning off into the
future here like i'm just gonna do drugs
and join a motorcycle gang and head like
that's something to grieve there's not a
lot you can do about that
yeah what you can do and you must do is
get involved on behalf of these little
kids because no other adult is stepping
up for them
i hate hate hate that you have to be the
one to do this because you're a big
sister
but nobody else is i'm just trying to
figure out like
well i'm like my my mom is also like
trying to figure it like we're both in
it like trying to figure out how do i
like go about i don't i don't even know
how to begin this conversation my dad
doesn't
he likes to deny yeah there is no there
is no conversation here's how this is
going to go down one you have a
conversation with your brother and you
say i can't keep my mouth shut about
this this is happening
number two you your mom not you but your
mom
files a custody request
with her attorney and said i've got
information that he used drugs using
meth with one of my other kids
and i'm no longer comfortable my kids
are no longer safe going to visit with
him and that should trigger some sort of
in the state of texas it was cps every
state's got different but child
protective services will get into an
investigation
and they will show up and potentially
drug test him they will potentially do a
house visit there's all kinds of things
that once that ball gets rolling
and all of that is i don't want a 10
year old in that environment
yeah and it's not even the motorcycle
stuff i don't have i don't have a
problem with it i don't know anything
about the gang but
i don't have a problem with that
inherently i have a problem with a dad
who's doing drugs with their kids
especially meth
for god's sake yeah i mean i don't like
know that he's doing that in front of
the younger kids and i would like to
hope that he has enough integrity not to
i mean he doesn't have the integrity to
do yeah you see there you go
here's the thing
you and your mom
have been talking in circles for a long
long long long time yeah
and somebody has to finally finally
finally be the adult
yeah and i hate that it's a falling on
you
because it should be dad and it should
be mom
yeah but somebody's got to do it and
your little brother your 21 year old he
he should know
he's gonna get in trouble and dad's
gonna call him a snitch there's gonna be
a whole bunch of thing and actually
what's gonna happen is he's gonna end up
denying it probably
he'll deny it or dad will deny it
there'll be a big he said she said or he
said he said whatever
and it'll cause drama and that's why you
got to get the attorneys involved
yeah and or the court involved and they
may do nothing
wouldn't surprise me
but
you at least let dad know hey this kind
of behavior is not cool even if you go
as his daughter and write him a letter
and say you can't do this with my
brothers and sisters they're my brothers
she can't can't do it
so like what if he just denies it
and
like how would i know if he's actually
honest about not doing it anymore has he
ever been honest with you before
no has your brother ever lied to you
all right that's that's a bad question
brother's a liar was he lying when he
told you
oh no most definitely not he felt
horrible he was almost crying telling me
about it there you go
so of course of course he's gonna deny
it there's no question about that yeah
yeah
so you're not doing an investigation to
see if this really happened what you're
doing is you're stepping in to protect
two children
yeah
and protecting means you're gonna call
the right people whether that's the
authorities whether that is
um
the courts whoever
and your mom's gonna be involved in that
and hopefully
hopefully
your mom steps in on behalf of those two
little kids
no she will okay i don't have doubt in
that yeah i think yeah we just both have
been so clueless on like i'm just scared
if we take what to be completely honest
i know that it's not fair for them to be
in the middle of it but i'm terrified of
what will
what my dad will do if he
loses custody of them just as far as i'm
alert already concerned about his will
to live
to be completely honest
so let me clear this up right now okay
if your dad hurts himself
that will not ever be on you
yeah
okay
yeah
do you believe me
um you don't and that's what i know what
you're saying that's okay
that's a great way to say that that's
that was
that was very eloquent suzanne yes
um you know what i'm saying is true but
you don't believe me and i get that
totally get that
um
he's had a hard row and he's making some
not healthy good smart choices and it's
heartbreaking to watch someone you love
uh fall apart
even if you reach out and tell dad i
love you but you can't do math around my
brothers can't do it if they can't i
can't have them be over there
um let's try a custody for a year at
mom's and we don't even have to get the
courts involved
and
once you get yourself cleaned up and
he'll fight and say no but at least you
can look him in the eye and say i love
you or write him my letters he can read
it over and over and over and over again
yeah
and maybe you don't love him and i don't
want to put that on you maybe he has
hurt you and your mom and your family
and now your little brother so long
that you're done with that part
now it's just about i'm gonna protect my
family
is that where you are yeah
um no i i do really love him i actually
didn't have a relationship with him
except for in the last three years we
were able to
build a relationship and then
all of this started happening and it
will he hear you
don't know how to be a woman
i
i don't know i i
doubt it honestly but
okay i would try
so if you're safe if you feel safe yeah
maybe that's the the breakfast
the breakfast meeting that i love so
much and you have a handwritten letter
that you hand him at that at that
breakfast can you say here it is i'm
worried about you you lost 100 pounds
it's clear that you're doing drugs i
can't have my brothers in this situation
i need you to know that i love you
um and i i
so want my dad back
and also
i've got to get in the middle and
protect my brothers
and so you can turn over custody for a
while you can let them come like miss
their visits for
six months for a year while you get
cleaned up
our mom's going has to go to court
that's the only option and that's the
choice he's making yeah not y'all right
yeah no you're right yeah it is so so
hard i'm sorry i'm heartbroken for you
susan
yeah
it's a lot
so yeah it's so much
and it's one of the old like not by your
hand but in your lap you didn't ask for
it and here it is bamo right
yeah but i keep one and whenever this
gets hard i always want to circle back
to those little kids
yeah and they have somebody
some that an adult has to step in for
them
has to step in for them
the uh
stay on the line here suzanne i'm gonna
give you i'ma send you a copy of this
new book my new book it's called own
your past change your future and it's
exactly what we're talking about here
you're gonna own this stuff that's hot
what's happened you gotta grieve it and
then you gotta be about doing the hard
gut
hard stuff of changing what comes next
[Music]
we'll be right back in the dr john
elonis show
for too long we've avoided the hard
conversations about mental health
relationships and the food we eat and i
don't want it to be true either but it
is the quality and quantity of the food
that we put into our body it matters and
oftentimes we're forced to decide
between cheap food that's good for our
budget or expensive food that's good for
our family but there's a company that
solved the problem greensbury is a
family-owned meat provider working with
farmers and fishermen all over the
country they sell organic grass-fed beef
free-range poultry pork lamb bison and
sustainable seafood their meat is less
expensive than what i can get at the
grocery store right down the street and
they deliver it to my door now listen
i'm a lunatic about meat quality and
this is the stuff i feed my family so go
to greensbury.com
and you'll get 10 off your first
purchase check it out today your
nutrition is worth it
all right we are back um
i'm gonna try something a little bit
different today we've been getting so
many emails and i feel bad we do three
shows we're talking about expanding the
number of shows we do talking about
expanding their emails we do i mean the
number of calls we do each show we just
get so many and some of these are so
good
um i wanted to
take just a few minutes answer a couple
of these emails real fast
um these are some great ones and
the either the caller didn't want to
decide they didn't want to be on the
show after all or
um just booking folks we got so many
calls lined up but we got this one call
here from san antonio
from jan it says
my son just revealed that his wife
confessed to a six-month long affair
with a co-worker
our family is understandably angry at
his wife but my son wants to work
through forgiveness and reconciliation
my question is how do we navigate this
as a family
showing love and forgiveness yet working
through the complete lack of trust we
all have for her and the hurt we feel
oh great great question this reminds me
of my friend
i think it's jennifer she's doing like
she is one of the best
the most wonderful people on the planet
and what makes her awesome is there's
been once a few times that she said hey
i met somebody
but i think you've talked about them are
we friends with them
and i love the way she asked that like
i'll burn their house down if we need to
but i kind of like them so if it's cool
like and so
i
have friends like like that i'm so right
or die with that are if you hurt my
friends if you hurt my family members
man it's hard for me it's hard i have a
loyalty issue pathologically so
and
when it comes to imagining somebody
cheating on like you know on my kid
the amount of hurt that would cause the
amount of devastation though all that
would just be so hard
and then my son turns and says or my
daughter turns and says
i'm going to work through this
i've forgiven her i'm asking you to
forgive her
i'm going gonna have her a part of my
life and if y'all want to be a part of
my life
she's she she's we're a package deal
so here's a couple of things um
that i would think through here number
one never ever ever ever talk bad about
his wife
two reasons number one you never know as
much as you think you know your son you
you as parents never know what's going
on behind closed doors same thing goes
with friends like my friend you never
know what's going on behind closed doors
not that there's ever an excuse to have
a six month long affair but i'm just
saying you never know what's going on
behind closed doors there's always
another side to a story
so that's why number one you don't talk
bad number two is if you come out of the
gate i can't believe she did this she's
a this she's a that oh my whatever
and then they get married or they stay
married and then she becomes the mother
of your grandkids
those words will always ring in her head
those words will always ring in your
son's head
so don't
don't talk bad
ask your son how he's doing
know that she is probably struggling to
i'm gonna say tell you something crazy
reach out and see how she's doing
because it looks like she is gonna be
bathed in shame and
guilt
and heartbreak
and all the mess that comes with this
so reach out to both of them and see if
they're doing okay
let her know if she needs anything
you'll be there
you'll respond and i know you forget
that dude if anyone hurts my son what
i'm telling you is finding somebody new
to hate
never solves anything
forgiveness does
and i know that's hard i know it's hard
so number one don't ever say anything
negative or bad
number two be very clear about your
boundaries
very clear whatever they happen to be
son if you get back with her
y'all will not be welcome in our home
that's your boundary be big boys and
girls and draw the boundary draw the
line
if you get back with him i'm taking you
out of the will i just need you to know
that
cool
if you go to that church i will not
support you if you whatever it happens
to be
if you're going to make your boundaries
make them clear
clear as kind say them out loud and hold
to them
the third thing here
is man
default to hospitality
invite him over
give her a hug
give him a hug
and then just turn the football game on
because as much as you want this to be
y'all's hurt your son's the one going
through this they're the one that have
to live with each other every day and
get up and go to bed and get up and go
to bed and make this thing work to
excavate everything and build something
else that's new
get along get on with forgiveness and
reconciliation
this is their journey
what they need is people to anchor in
and love them and support them
and
not to be judgmental be like i saw her
on her phone do you know what that don't
do that don't do that
hug them both when they come in if he
says she's back then she's back
or unless that violates one of your
boundaries
and the meta here is
ah man
freaking facebook took meta
from me i got to come up with another
word
unbelievable
the big overarching balloon umbrella
thing
i don't know what to call it ben that's
your job come up with a new meta word i
don't know what it is but i'll think of
something
is default to forgiveness default to
hospitality
man
default to hugs first and i know that
makes me sound cliche and lame and
cheesy but it's right
all right and then one more email from
andra she says
you're always using the phrase spin-out
i'd never heard it before and i've
always tried to gather your meaning from
context
but you don't have a lot of context just
kidding she didn't say that but i don't
think my guesses have been correct is it
a metaphor or colloquial idiom
colloquial idiom well played you're
somebody who uses big grown-up words
i use spin out yeah dude
this is a technical term can you please
clarify how you mean it so when i say
spin out it is it's a cloak it's it is
kind of a catch-all term for
when you think why did he leave his
shoes out he knows that i hate it
because he lifts his shoes up
he always just does things because he
knows he's gonna consider my skin
because he knows that it makes me mad
and when i get mad i get irrational and
he doesn't like you when i'm rushed he
likes somebody else i knew it i know
he's cheating and all that as he left
his shoes out there that's what i'm
talking about spinning out when your
thoughts get pushed down a hill and it's
hard to catch them um hard to get them
back hard to rein them back in you are
watching the news and they have a clip
of a president or a clip of a
congressman or woman or something like
that and
you get angry and you start to think
what about my kids
my kids if they don't deal with this
then my kids are gonna be and then all
of a sudden you are selling putting all
of your retirement into bitcoin and
you're digging a hole in the backyard
for you and your family to that's what
i'm talking about spinning out
you can also spin out when you're angry
you can also spin out it's when your
emotions
override your critical thinking ability
it's when your emotions become the
driver
of whatever is going on in your life
that is spinning out
so i wish it was some fancy diagnostic
it's not you can't really google spin
out you probably could it's probably a
skateboard term or something but that's
what i mean when it comes to spin out so
great question
um i have learned throughout this
podcast that i use words that
only me and my high school buddies used
or college buddies used and not a lot of
other people in america use them so
there you go we'll maybe we'll do a uh
delonism's definition show one day
that'd be a sad show
do you feel like you're always busy
doing something lists chores work stuff
kid stuff pet stuff all of it but you're
never getting anywhere in the areas of
life you really care about like in your
relationships with friends taking care
of your body connecting with your spouse
a romantic partner loving your kids
then it's time to look at the things
you're doing and how your actions are
keeping you from where and who you want
to be
if your actions aren't working for you
anymore that's okay
now is your chance to get up and choose
differently and that doesn't have to be
complicated in fact in my new book own
your past change your future we'll walk
through a common sense approach to
mental health and wellness including
steps to change your actions and move
you closer towards the person you want
to be
if you pre-order today we'll give you
hundreds of dollars of free bonus items
so go to johndaloni.com to start
creating the life you want that's own
your past change your future at
johndaloni.com
james what do you think uh
the ggds or these guys
we gotta go with
the dolls right
no yeah do it these were both conor's
picks so
connor
are these your bands
you love them
don't ever tell anybody that you need to
keep that secret to yourself
but
connors the youtube guru back here
favorite song of all time
ever
google dolls song is better days or
[Laughter]
is this what you think of when you're
having to work on the show like there's
better days out there somewhere
and it goes like this
and you ask me what i want this year a
new job and i try to make this kind and
clear just a chance that maybe we'll
find better days
i'm taking this personal connor because
i don't need boxes wrapped in strings
and designer love and empty things just
a chance that maybe we'll find better
days and john will move on so take these
words and sing out loud cause everyone
is forgiven now because tonight's the
night the world begins again i need some
place simple where we could live and
something only you could give and that's
faith and trust and peace while we're
alive and the one poor child who saved
this world and there's 10 million more
who probably could we all just stopped
and said a prayer for them
because everyone is forgiven now because
tonight's the night the world begins
again and conor
[Music]
gets a new job we'll be right back on
the dr john dolani show